un candidat deux recruteurs toutes les
conditions sont réunies pour donner
l'impression à mehdi qu'ils passent un
entretien d'embauché
il s'agit pourtant d'un entraînement
pour le jeune homme comme lui les
stagiaires de l'école de la deuxième
chance des yvelines font face matin-là à
des professionnels pendant 25 minutes
objectif les tester mais surtout leur
donner confiance avant de décrocher un
vrai rendez vous ça leur permet de se
situer en fin de compte dans leur
accompagnement ça leur permet de prendre
confiance en eux dans le cadre de leur
démarche de travail et leur projet
professionnel avec plus de confiance de
de pouvoir s'épanouir
il était positif ils m'ont dit que vu
que c'était une passion que je voulais
mettre en oeuvre dans un métier ça
pourrait être intéressant j'aurai tout
pour conquérir
en tout 25 jeunes ont participé à cette
matinée spéciale pour les aider dit
recruteurs locaux ont répondu à l'appel
ce premier contact avec le monde de
l'entreprise doit permettre aussi à ses
stagiaires en formation depuis plusieurs
mois de diversifier leurs compétences il
ya le marché de l'emploi et on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de concurrence dans le
marché de l'emploi il faut que ces
jeunes soient prêts aussi à faire face à
ceux à ce marché de l'emploi cette
concurrence et pour ça il faut qu'ils
puissent réussir à faire un super
entretien pour pouvoir décrocher leur
premier leur premier emploi
depuis leur lancement il ya vingt ans
les écoles de la deuxième chance ont
accueilli des jeunes sans diplôme de 16
à 25 ans en 2016 85 % des stagiaires ont
bénéficié d'une sortie positive
alternance formation qualifiante ou
contrat aidé le département des yvelines
compte trois écoles dont une à saint
quentin en yvelines